A mating ritual of the human.
is a mind-boggling dance.
First, the male chooses
a mate who is much more
intelligent and attractive
than he is.
Then he begins to
obsess over her,
consulting her Facebook page
up to 50 times a day,
often pleasuring himself
to her likeness
to the point of exhaustion.
Months can pass with no word
from the mate.
[cell phone vibrates]
Then, suddenly...
- Linda?
narrator: She will
make contact.
- No, no, it's not a problem.
I'm right nearby.
I'll be right there.
narrator: Usually when
she needs help
moving large objects.
Or when somebody else
has canceled
their plans with her
last-minute.
Somewhere in this
complex dance,
procreation occurs.
- Well, I got a lot of notes.
For starters, I think we need
ten more frames
of Jeff jerking off
to help with the pacing.